hello and welcome to this video
playing black against
louise michelle but in a weird way
um spelled in a
somewhat odd way okay so we get a tromp
i had one just some games ago
just a different line
f3 bishop d6 is a fun variation
which i had analyzed for them for the
benko gambit repertoire
i have forgotten the details but i know
that this was
quite reasonable e5 queen
h4 g3 queen before check something
weird like that
it was very messy but
i've got a pretty reasonable score
against
this player knight or
knight h3 okay
i don't know
before with slow
i can probably cancel them
this queen age form b for business
should still work with knight h3 and
castling inserted
i always have to think about this move
what to do with the knight
and also in combination with the capture
de-6d6 check
on h4 check
i can always take b2 at the end
yeah it would be really good to know to
know stuff in this position
but as i said i have forgotten the
details
yeah do we take here or
what are we doing here in beef b form
anyway i can do that right
d takes d takes e5 knight f5 must be
fine there's a huge square there
yeah yeah that looks good
one idea is bishop to bishop to b7
trying to
take here and isolate that pawn
yeah bishop e2 on something like that
trying to castle
after e5
even knight c4 is a thing
because e5 knight c4 takes in this queen
h4
i would still probably go to f5
because those squares look really juicy
well white is taking a long time here so
we'll see what
happens this move i did not really have
on the radar i mean
i i did but i thought it's not really um
dangerous i can just take
and this this structure looks really
good
so check or
you can check or knight f5 and knight f5
is also a move
but i think checking first looks really
good
bishop e2 knight f5
oh really c4
for queen b6
i can also check here check their g3
queen d4
check and then take b2 it's also pretty
strong
it looks really awful
maybe i can even
find something better it looks like
there could be could be a wind somewhere
knight here is also pretty difficult to
play against knight e4 probably then
queen f6 is also nice
wow i don't don't know what oops what's
best because
pretty much everything looks strong
okay i know let's play this
this is an idea b2 is hanging
knight f5 is also
a thing but then knight e4 maybe is no
that i could actually take
that that opening is difficult you have
to play for both sides and if white has
no
um prior knowledge it's it's it's
difficult to navigate
when e4 b5 and now knight h3 so i think
castling
should be fine and then a4 i think
around here you have to look for
improvements
a4 that doesn't help yeah
b4 is just taking away some good squares
for white and the dark squares are
really weak in white's camp
you know i thought what the engine is
basically stating bishop e2
has to be done and then you just play
this position
you should be seven takes
i'm happy here the dark squares are
problematic for white but it's not
nothing terrible yeah 92 and here
i think taking
and rookie 8 yeah it looks pretty awful
and it was difficult to judge because so
many moves look strong queen f6 seems to
be one of the
one of the stronger moves though
yeah and what do you do now this is just
so difficult
the check this is hanging yeah knight c4
is
a blunder but what can you do here
no it's just a very bad position okay
guys thanks for watching